so I'm gonna disappoint you right off
the bat and say this is not a problem
that individuals can fix uh you know
people love to talk about oh you should
take your car a little less you should
eat a little less so paper straws are
not going to fix climate change no so
these all good things are available damn
please yeah feel free to do them and
they're probably good for other things
but don't believe that this is a
question about us you know doing a
little lesson then we've fixed it the
main issue here is that there is about
you know somewhere between four and six
billion people out there the non-rich
people in this world who want to be rich
that's China India Africa and they want
to get out of poverty and yeah you can't
blame them they will want to do that by
producing much more by becoming rich
just like we are and that will emit a
lot more CO2 unless we have a different
technology to take over